تتحدث مع صديقك حول شيء ما وما ان تمسك
هاتفك حتى تشاهد اعلانا لنفس الشيء امر
شائع اليس كذلك التفسير البديهي ان
هواتفنا تستمع الينا لكن المفاجاه ان ذلك
لا يحدث طبقا لكثير من خبراء التقنيه
وكبرى الشركات التي تنكر ذلك
في الواقع لا تحتاج التطبيقات الى التنصت
لمحادثاتك لاظهار اعلان لمنتج او خدمه ما
يكفيها ان تتعرف على سجل البحث الخاص
المواقع المفضله عاداتك في التسوق
الالكتروني المشتريات السابقه ثم مشاركه
هذه المعلومات مع المعلمين طيب ماذا نفعل
حتى نطمئن ببساطه يمكن ان نختار ان يصل
التطبيق لبعض خصوصياتنا الا وقت استخدامه
فقط
[موسيقى]
في النهايه نحن من نسمح للتطبيقات بتشغيل
الكاميرا او الميكروفون او الوصول الى
معرض الصور والفيديوهات ومواقعنا يفضل
ايضا ان تاخذ جوله في هاتفك وتحذف
التطبيقات التي لا تحتاجها ولم تستخدمها
لاشهر وفي حال لازلت لا تشعر بالراحه
يمكنك تعطيل المساعد الصوتي سيري او جوجل
التي تستمع لمحادثاتك ترقبا الاستجابه وقت
ما يتطلب من هذا ذلك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]